RYAN: Hi.
I'm Ryan, and today I'm super
excited to talk about powering
API operations with AI and ML.
Let's get to it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So why is API
operations important?
Well, APIs are packages
of data and functionality
that developers use to build
new digital experiences quickly
and easily.
Since they encompass business
critical information,
it's extremely important
for operations teams
to ensure the APIs are always
available and performing
as expected.
But as API programs
scale, it becomes
practically impossible to
manage individual APIs.
To reduce manual
overhead and operators,
Apigee brings the power of
Google's industry-leading AI
and machine learning
to your APIs.
A great example of such a use
case is anomaly detection.
Anomaly detection
applies AI-powered rules
that trigger alerts based on a
set of predefined conditions.
This eliminates the
need for operators
to manually adjust the
monitoring thresholds on APIs.
As API traffic
changes by season,
auto-adjusted thresholds reduce
a lot of false alert noise.
Therefore, operators
can now focus
on things that really
matter to their business.
Let's take a closer
look at this feature.
You can view all anomaly
events under the API Monitoring
menu of Apigee.
It shows a complete list of
anomalies identified by Apigee.
Using the power of
machine learning,
these events are auto-generated
based on historical API data.
This eliminates
the need for users
to manually set up alerts.
The actionable link on
each of these events
will take you to an Investigate
view of the anomaly.
Here, you can see that
the error rate surged
at around 4 o'clock,
and the system
was able to catch the anomaly.
Below the graph, you can see
the fault code, which shows
the root cause of this anomaly.
You can further
investigate this event
by adding more layers,
such as API Proxy.
This shows the details of the
proxy for which this event was
triggered.
You can also use this
analysis to identify
the source of the error.
In this case, you can see that
the fault source of the proxy
is the Apigee platform.
In addition to the
system-generated events,
you can also set up alerts to
get real-time notifications
when anomaly events
are triggered.
The alert can be set up by
creating an alert policy
in Google Cloud's
monitoring service.
Once an alert is triggered,
you'll get a notification.
Here is a snapshot
of an email alert.
It provides complete
details of the anomaly,
such as Timestamp, Project,
Policy, and Threshold buttons.
Users can click on the
View Incident button
to quickly investigate and find
the root cause of the error.
In summary, Apigee
brings the power
of Google's industry-leading
AI with features
like anomaly detection to
simplify API operations
so that you can deliver seamless
and connected experiences
for your customers.
Now it's your turn
to try it out and get
started by following the links
in the description below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]